if it's okay we want to talk real estate
with you in the news
oh my god nothing else we like to do
more perfect
well a recent survey actually said that
many people would
happily skip sex to serve zillow
i mean i don't think of online as a
porn opportunity i think of it as a real
estate opportunity yeah
yeah people are into some freaky stuff
and my fetish is a sunken living room
and an open concept kitchen
that's what i mean too and no shame yep
exactly
start on a good school district oh my
god
[Laughter]
all right well we got some properties we
want to get your opinion on here's a hot
one
in lake tahoe it's a duplex it offers 2
000 square feet for the small price tag
of 650 000
and the daily mail reports it comes
complete with rooms and rooms
of dressy mannequins mannequins
glamorously lounging about the living
space dressed to the nines near the
the kitchen uh you know this place will
cost an arm and a leg
that's so stupid uh okay natasha did 650
thousand dollars and
you get the mannequins is that a seal
okay here's the problem there is no good
way to get rid of that many mannequins
without seeming like a serial killer
the most i'm saying for me is that all
these mannequins are wearing outfits
that natasha owns and that's what really
freaked out
oh my god i wish it was like that kim
cattrall movie remember mannequin oh
and then there was mannequin too like on
the move or something
yeah i kind of fast forward through that
one yeah
okay our next listing went viral because
it's just oozing with 1970s charm the
new haven register reports that this
four
bedroom in fort wayne indiana is covered
in
wall to wall shag carpet all
2476 square feet designed in 1975 by
architect james
sherbondi the carpets and stains are all
original the stains are original drew's
in
i know by the way i'm like let me at
this house with a bottle of draft
a family from orlando put in an offer
before stepping
foot into the place damn natasha
thoughts
this house is kind of looking to me like
ross matthews house if he never left his
hometown
you don't even know how dead on that is
right i actually was looking at those
pictures thinking to myself like
it's not bad i'm kind of into it i mean
look that house for starters those lines
that that's beautiful
the carpet is literally hot watermelon
color
i mean the shad goes up to the edge of
the tub can you imagine
that that carpet has never been changed
even imagine what is inside that carpet
i don't want to
kind of house where they you have to
take off your shoes and put on platform
shoes
to not step on the crunchy spots
my god i kind of love it all right next
up the sight house beautiful posted
about a
two bed two bath house in uh
zephyr hills florida it's described as
quote literally
the worst house on the street okay
listen to this the roof leaks
the floor creeks and there's quote a
terrible draft throughout the house
which means it's very open concept in
that also
several of the windows are broken and
despite all of that it sold
for 51 000 so what do you think the new
owners are planning to do
good investment well all i know is that
in la
this house is 1.7 million
this is the kind of house you had to
wear a mask
you know during the open house but it
was before copenhagen
exactly but i kind of love the optimism
in that
somebody looked at that house and
thought there's something beautiful here
i love that the realtor
was just straight up honest and what was
like yes
this is a piece of you-know-what it's
got no walls
it's it's a it's a dump it's a disaster
and it's 51 000.
that honesty i found very refreshing
okay and finally we've got an adorable
story about some
mini real estate in calabasas buzzfeed
reports that kim kardashian has built an
adorable
tiny town in her backyard for her kids
just take a look at these pics
oh my gosh i know there's a diner an ice
cream shop and
and even a mini kkw beauty
store don't you want it like the little
ross wants a little town like that i
wish i could go on my childhood and
there'd be like you
know a drag brunch place there a little
cabaret theater for me like the french
market quarter yeah
west hollywood yes um natasha dan what
would you want
i would want like a teeny little day spa
where i could get my nose done
or
you know what i want i want to get rid
of these wrinkles right here you know
like whatever that is like puff them up
a little bit yeah
get some lego injections whatever you
need
you guys can we please do this again a
hundred percent
our schedules are wide open
dan levy and natasha legero we love you
please let this be the first of so many
and you can catch these very funny
humans
to do a set at none other than banana
mores
a virtual comedy club
we crushed it i will tell you right now
we were the funniest people on
i am so excited about bananamores
because it launches this saturday on our
youtube channel
and i just thought you know comedy clubs
are
closed right now and i know they're
trying to figure out
their way back um but we all need to
laugh
so thank you so much natasha and dan
and of course obviously you can catch
them on house hunters comedians on
couches unfiltered on discovery plus
right now it is the most delicious way
to spend your time
i love it and i love you guys i'm so
happy for you well done you guys
[Music]